Salam alaikum how's everybody let's wake
everybody get good at humber de nada
everybody I'm very excited we're trying
to share because we care and that's why
we do the program
Disha which is viewed internationally
all over the globe and we're here with
you guys we're here with you guys
and I get the benefit first and foremost
because I get to sit with some of the
students of knowledge people who have
accepted Islam and I get to soak in this
knowledge and then press record and
share with you today doing a live show
so for our youth that are out there
struggling this difficult gourd up in
the West year many of the challenges you
have to wake up on times and make the
prayer you have to stay away from
certain things so it's a lot of do's and
don'ts so we want to give some
encouragement not only to the youth but
also the parents who are here to try to
understand the youth so what better way
then they get some advice from our
brothers here we also haven't grown up
in this culture myself included I was
born and raised here I'm an American and
we can speak that we speak the
vernacular language so sometimes with
your father mother telling you this that
and the other and it goes in from one
ear out the other
but when you're talking to somebody who
can relate inshallah sinks a little bit
better so I have two of our brothers
insha'Allah
we've been on additional Muslims allow
yeah sure you Josh for evidence and
shall our soon-to-be Umar Asian so we're
going to start off by having them
introduce themselves starting from my
right to the left go ahead
Salam aleikum Rockville I am very
capable malarek and Allah
my name is you Sean Evans born and
raised in South Carolina I accept
1998 but humbly left rabid enemy and
have been working since then to Sheriff
Michael
my name is Omar reading I'm Layla and my
mother accepted Islam when I was five
years old so I'm what I said I'm wali
krama hunt alive out of character
my name is Muslim balakian I was born
and raised in the United Kingdom London
South London I embraced Islam in 2002
and having did a ladder journey
continues to it I'm going to be asking
you guys a question so the viewers here
can get to benefit from the responses
now you guys grown up in the West
you've also faced some of those
challenges alhamdulillah many of us are
still facing challenges to this day it's
a struggle is that you had all the way
till we visit that grave so we want to
do enough good just please our crater
before we meet our critters so we need
that good advice as I mentioned
sometimes when you get an advice from it
from an old uncle we respect our uncle's
from you know you guys ain't that old
but when we get people who are more our
age bracket or who've been there done
that we've kind of respected a little
bit better so tell us what were some of
the challenges that you guys faced
growing up here and how did you overcome
these things such as going to the
nightclubs things as you know when
people are in the Masjid you're out you
know partying and hanging out and the
call comes with you know the prayer but
then the friends are calling you know
you did to be out with them so that's a
dilemma that we're facing how did you
guys overcome that let's start with fun
we start let's talk mister blah so hon a
lot for me I was scared when I first
became a Muslim if I'm honest I was
scared of the rules a brothel was giving
me dower I told him I'm I'm
Siddalee becoming a Muslim and it's
important in the manner of reason which
we give dower is he scared me tell him
he decided to tell me everything is
Haram so it's like he said let this
newsy that you're doing it is Haram you
know he'd have to stop that and also
this going out the clubs etc you'd have
to stop down I said okay we'll go out
but I won't drink alcohol you know just
have a good time no no no no going out
all together
forget the alcohol said okay watch my
friend's birthday is that no birthdays
as well forget so everything seemed her
arm and it's just mixing in general all
these women and it scared me you know
when you're young you the world is like
a playground to you and you just you
just see enjoyment and everything
because you don't have much
responsibilities at a young age so you
just want to have fun and it sounded
like everything that was fun was Haram
and everything that was fun and
enjoyable I can't do no more
so what's this last gonna be like for me
if I become a Muslim now at 19 years old
it's life's gonna be boring and it's
gonna be that I wanted to delay it to a
later age unless I said maybe I'll
become a Muslim when I'm 30 or 40 after
I've had all my crackers but we don't
have this contract saying we're gonna
live for this long so basically it was
it was the fear of death when I spoke to
someone else it was the fear of dying in
that bad state and not having that time
you know a lot of us being old later
running laughs for people of almost a
thing after I get married after
university we delay it we don't hasten
towards good and it was the fear of
dying and being raised on that day
qiyamah when he was the guy who's giving
me Dawa with more wisdom he was
explaining about being raised as like
the winners or to lose and it was the
fear of being raised as a loser that
just made me finger I have to try now so
I accepted it from 19 and the journey
just started about stye but believe me
it wasn't easy and it's still not easy
like there's there was many things that
I was battling with but for the me as a
rapper it was when some young Muslim
sorry to get to the point some young
Muslims are doing it a calf in a mosque
and it was the Imams children and they
came up to me and Eric
as misery on Pakistan occurs allow
you're a rapper a rapper do a rap do a
rap I said I didn't want to do I do
embarrassing me I said you recite some
Quran and he was reciting what sham see
what I have for me and us and they said
don't you know it I'm my little brother
knows it's in just a Marine he's five so
not knowing it but knowing all that rap
kind of that made me Christian lack I'm
like no I can rap along to so much rap
CDs etc but when the Quran plays how
long can I go on for I don't so it just
made me question where's my heart see
it's just that it was that battle
basically like where's your heart when
the questions come to you what did you
really love in this life was it you say
we love Allah redeemed but our actions
are showing something different it was
cheap
yeah talk is cheap yeah you have any
regrets any regrets
yeah you missing party somebody all
flown on and there's no there's no
enjoyment in it like there's no
enjoyment in it not at all so you're
happy now alhamdulillah
Omar let's just move on
how do you we talked about the tantalize
ation of this world you thought I mean
you're like right in at all the
Hollywood glitz and glamour and the
movies made and now it's like are you
going to wear to the after-party is that
what it's all about and now it's a red
carpet and all the you know paparazzi
and it's like you know everything's
mixed districts that all sort of
martinis and how you not succumb to that
and say on the right way the way that's
pleasing to the greater so how mom oh
man
well hamdullah it's um it's a big
problem to be honest with everybody you
really have to let me tell you I'm going
to tell you the short story you you it
becomes a point where you start seeing
yourself and the environment that you're
in and you all of us have this voice on
the right side of us to remind us like
you shouldn't be here
you should you really shouldn't be here
and then you're looking around I was I
went to this event and Hum Dil I was I
was with a man
um it was Dave Chapelle it was uh Wesley
Snipes we was there and was Abdullah
Chappelle's his brother I was at this
event and we were going we had good
intentions
I mean youngsters we wanted to talk to
Prince Faisal was there with the
Hollywood studios and I wrote the script
and I wanted to talk to him about doing
some Muslim halal movies that's what I
wanted to do and he had the money and I
wanted to talk to him say give me the
money but I had to go into this to this
party and it was on the Sunset Strip and
not genuine was there LisaRaye was there
all these other celebrities was there
that you know you have to lower our
gauge sisters even had to lower their
gaze with the genuine guy we know but it
was at this point when I realized that I
was wasting my time I was there and look
how I got the reminder I'm
in there and I felt so shamed because
it's the time when Michael Jackson was
had passed away and I was they was
playing a Michael Jackson song and I was
[Music]
and this woman she was tall she she
approached me and was like you're the
only one this is my reflection I was
like oh ha ha
and all the people I'm thinking like I'm
Muslim and I'm the one that danced in
the Michael Jackson so she's talking to
me now I've must I don't remember what I
said to be honest I don't know what I
said if she loves she's like you Muslim
I was like oh yeah and she's very tall
she had just miniskirt on and she's like
she was a model and she said oh that's
nice and then I was like she she's also
looking up to I was like wow was photo
ok
and she said other than vulgar and let
me tell you ma'am I immerse on her
because I didn't know what that meant
many more grip right and so I was like
you from so loud to longer but then she
said Morocco and so I was like wow and I
looked at it and she said leave this
what she honestly Eddie she looked at me
in her eyes water and she said please
say Fatiha with me and I was touched
like I was like and that's messed up but
I didn't know like I really I started
thinking about all of the shitty open
airy pain like this is this was this has
got to be if today but but I was like
well I messed up and she's messed up too
so we might work a funky huh
I'm sick [ __ ] hot and then she was
like I want to know how much it is and
everything and I said wow what if that
was me I walked away from her and this
is this lady was talking to me and this
guy was black and he was looking at me
she took me to introduce me to him and
this guy and he was the manager in
charge of Erica by doing everything and
he was like you want to drink and offer
you a drink
it's real it's an honor when I turned
the drink down I was dishonouring him it
was like I said no no I don't drink and
everybody just so I was like you know I
was like oh and then the other ladies
like oh he's Muslim
hey Danny oh you must have almost a
supersonic on flight but captain and he
pulled out his a lot of chain as if it
was his badge to be like BAM and he
started talking to me out of it
coming in and I was like and I cut them
out of the area and the nature of him I
don't understand
and the point it got to me I started
looking awesome
you know what I already left it's a
bunch of mushrooms in here and look at
how we look and I don't look no better I
got to make a decision like I do not
want to just blend in with the crowd
I want to I wanted that that experience
it really bothered me because I was like
man I look just like everybody else I
don't look like anybody that's making
sure live that's a reminder of a love
that you know what I mean just this I
like what I am why like inspiring
America Muslim youth I don't look like
that
I'm misrepresented everything and it
really made me feel shame and it just
stuck with me it's a little funny but it
shook me and it's very difficult to be
in that kind of environment
I mean I've done some film mounting
intelligent Muslims which film out
because I'll be like oh I would be left
on Shane just not even I was grateful
that I really have any bad scenes but
just because I was there and then if you
saw the movie if you like use them you
know it's just too much it's really too
much and it comes a point where I don't
talk too too long
I just come a point where we have to
make a commitment to being who we really
truly are like we don't really realize
how a los Amidala has given us the light
and they they want the light that people
look for the light well how am I gonna
shine on the right if I'm gonna mix of
all of this is they don't just block the
light and then nobody be like hey move
out the way and I'm gonna shine it's not
gonna work it's just not gonna work so
we just can't be putting on we got to
try our best
like like listen I'm saying we got to
try our best because it's the constant
struggle and be strong I am not afraid
to stand alone if Eliza
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if allies by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone
I started asking deeper question
the question I want people to really ask
themselves is when you come back from a
night on the town
you've been drinking you've been boozing
you've been dancing then you're hanging
out with girls guys whatever number one
did you improve yourself is human being
number two did you contribute anything
to the betterment of humanity the
amazing thing is is that the most
advanced studies in psychology about
human happiness show that these are the
two key factors in making people
profoundly happy I take five minutes out
of my day and prayed to the Creator and
none of the creations and I feel a deep
internal peace and I still have my
normal life get the experience from you
shot Evans you've been on a date show
before hung a lot of people go to see
your whole story at the Dean show calm
so you also made a transition from
living that lifestyle of chasing your
lusts and desires so in short how did
you overcome that to where you are today
what keeps you going listen up from that
I said I'm sort of that you know 13
years ago almost 14 years ago when I
accepted his name I was at a point while
I was trying to get out of that
lifestyle I really you know didn't have
realized I didn't have a place here in
the first in the first place and I was
striving to get out and so when I found
this land it was like finding home you
know I was like I had found what needed
to be and belonged but 14 years later
after going through so many different
things in within being a Muslim dealing
with my family the biggest probably
tribulation that came to me was not from
non-muslim there wasn't for my family
from the Muslim community because when I
first accepted Islam this was before
9/11
you know people weren't entering a
standard rule because in Amazon the
media no I was just some weird white guy
you know in the magic the only white guy
in the Masjid and it was somewhat hard
for me to find my place you know it was
almost like I was still an outside I had
left my whole way of life and become an
outsider to everyone else and then I was
sitting outside and it's not the
community and everybody was even me
everything
read this read that studied this you
need to know this you need to know that
I didn't know where to start with where
ABCD went anything so 14 years later
what I think really keeps me going in
being able to go and try to bring other
people out of that darkness is one day I
was sitting on a plane half asleep and
this is something that I think all of us
especially really quickly show of hands
how many people here born born and
raised in his name know how many people
came to a snap reverts very small number
in the room so I'm speaking to all of
you born and raised in its nest I was
sitting on a plane one day half asleep
and for some reason remembering I was
preparing for a lecture and I was
thinking about the hadith of the prophet
alayhi salaatu wa salaam about Allah
Azza WA JAL having written everything in
a book that is only with him fifty
thousand years before he initiated
creation everything there would happen
as we know the puppet is allowed to sin
and said the first thing I'm afraid it
was the fell of the pin and then he told
the pin the write up and said write what
he said write every everything and then
I thought to myself you know what
somewhere in that book allah wrote that
you would be guided
somewhere in that book a lot of roads
and had written that you would be guided
that you would come out from that
darkness and into the light of the flood
and be where you are right now and that
kind of overwhelmed because now haven't
really understood who my Creator is
really understanding Allah that Allah
would consider guiding someone
like me out of all of humanities is
really a favor and in that matter I
didn't do anything to deserve I don't do
anything to continue to deserve it
forget that guidance is still there and
so now it becomes more of an issue to me
not to struggle to stay inside of this
man anymore
but to struggle each and every day to
repay a debt that I can never repay to
all ma because he's given me something
that's prices which is life and there is
nothing I can do in a myriad of
lifetimes to repay that debt so every
morning I wake up now with the
consideration that what am I going to do
today to try to repay that gift that was
given to me before I was even thought of
before the creation was thought of where
Allah had written down in a book that is
only with him that I would be guided and
for all of you here in this room a lot
of wrote your name in that book to that
name your name was written in that book
too so Allah put in consideration to
bring you to Islam and I don't know what
any of you have done to deserve it but
if you are like I am we didn't do
anything to deserve it it is truly a
gift it is truly an honor that was given
to us and every single day that we wake
up and were able to say Lila hi Lavazza
it's another gift and and that's really
the beautiful treasure of Islam that we
try to share with the world that it is a
gift and it was given to me 14 years ago
and I tried to give it to as many people
as I can that that's only thing that
keeps me going if not I don't even know
what I would be doing right now
we shall love it
I don't want to have all the fun so
we're going to try to take a couple
questions you have a few minutes left on
the topic to learn their experiences we
haven't any sisters we'll start with the
sisters any sisters I'm sister once I
asked this question ad for a friend
who's be challenged by today's high is
maybe she's her Prentice barely got over
here and all the other friends was
trying to have her at that part you can
keep here so some advice from the
brothers that I would say anybody raise
your hand just wrote me okay
go ahead and that's your question thank
you so much
my own struggle with that yes I was born
with sin and I'm so thankful that I'm a
Muslim well why are you accident Wilson
and some that have to say it soldier
asked you all day but their hearts are
applying it what why would I so much to
do a movement and some people that I can
share my watching it with them they
don't see it so beautiful question go
ahead if you vote all three of you can
maybe hit it for one minute each before
we take another question go ahead
I don't think I fully understood the
question why are we so lucky to be
guided she wants to share it with you no
guidance it is from Allah like all we
can do is convey a message the guidance
is from Allah so we have to do our duty
it's not really our duty to change the
world and to get frustrated or angry at
the rest of the world etc we can this
conveyor message in the best manner
manners we have possible and hope that
Allah guides them and the way I've say
is to change ourselves to by having
beautiful characters and by having the
best of manners and inshallah I will
attract them to want to join us or to be
interested in what it is that we have
yep that's right now I agree he said
everything I mean I'm Lila he said
everything be grateful and then if you
grateful then you're happy and you're
happy and you're smiling and I think
what happens to a lot of people is they
get turned off from Islam because they
don't they don't see Muslim smiling you
know so I think that we have to smile
more and show that we are really truly
excited and grateful to Allah for him
even making us Muslim and then you know
that we know because this is natural to
want a party to want to drink to want to
have fun to want to have do Haram all at
a time is not who we are as human beings
it's not who Allah created as man that's
things that like insert a nest or law so
Allah says that we seek refuge in Allah
from pseudo Denese the whispers from
that going to the heart that feeling or
that emotion is not real it's whispered
into us so being Muslim is natural
we got it we're going to pass it to you
sha Russia um as far as the question why
are we the lucky ones that's a question
that we can't really answer I can't even
tell you why I'm on guidance solo but
when it comes to uh sharing the message
of Islam with people even our Muslim
family members that are not practicing
friends that are not practicing you know
and they are exposed to the same things
we're exposed to but yet they are not
coming on board you know this is a
question that plagues our beloved
messenger salallahu alayhi wasalam as
well and Allah Azza WA JAL revealed to
him will you destroy yourselves over
their footsteps will you destroy
yourself over their footsteps their
comings and goings and they're running
away from you Allah told him you cannot
guide whomever you wish it is I who
guide whomever I wish and I know best
who is guided I know who is best astray
one thing I tried to share with everyone
and this is maybe something you can take
home with you tonight when I meet people
and give them that away I tell them
something very simple they look when it
comes to your relationship with your
Creator it is personal relationship it
is personal it is I have it with me it
doesn't have anything to do with all the
your mother this is a relationship
between you and the one who created you
so I implore you to do something if you
really want to know the truth about your
life and your existence then go to the
one who created you simply humbly ask
him got you to the truth and also ask
that with sincerity and they are willing
to follow that path wherever it may lead
it will lead to guidance because Allah
says we guide those who walk aright so
that is simply and humbly those who wish
to follow the path of Allah as well and
Allah gives them to be able to go on
that path
we're taking one question from one of
the brothers let me get a hand you have
a question anybody have a question from
his side go ahead okay go ahead young
brother friends but if I offended you no
you don't want to I mean we know that
God is warning and trying to send a
message how do we send a match without
touch again and also sometimes they
agree with the message but they don't
it's the identity because it's also
something within our core you know what
emotions are something like that so how
did it how do you fight that Danny
battle and how do we speak on without
offending them because of what we are
once a super guy doc we got 30 seconds
the answers a question you shut up if
you don't go to your right 30 times
one problem we have had here in in in
the West a lot with Dawa is to learn how
to make Islam Universal because Islam is
you religion everyone not content to any
time or place it's not constricted to
any time a place that's not a lot of
religion it's not a Pakistani religion
when it comes to sharing the message
without being overbearing Allah Azza WA
JAL has given us that key very simply
when he commanded a sir oh dear o allah
say arabic abelhammer
the first command was called to the way
of your lord with wisdom and wisdom is
according to the best definition we give
the English language wisdom is to use
knowledge at the right place at the
right time with do discretion so we have
to know how to share Islam with our
brothers and sisters in humanity and I
finish with this last statement that we
do need to be trained and our that way
is something that needs to be learned it
is a technique it is a skill it is a
proficiency but lastly I want to explain
to you the last hadith is that the
prophet alayhi salaatu wa salaam said as
you all know you do not love for your
brother with you so you do not have true
belief until you love for your brother
what you love for yourself
mmm and now we'll hang the whole
to Allah when interpreting this hadith
he said Brotherhood in this sense meant
general that you do not have true Eman
until you love for your fellow human
being what you love for yourself and
what we love for our self is Jenna so we
should love that for them too and show
them sincerity that we have care and
concern for you this much for the male
of female that face down and out they
feel like a hit rock bottom
she's been using abuse by the man she
should have been there and now she's got
a relationship and you know what she's
trying to being an x-ray and he's also
manipulated with the women and he took
all the parties and now he's like you
know what I just don't want to do it no
more and you're feeling this skilled
inside she's old it's the other side if
you like you know what this is hope for
me is there hope you want to know you've
been there done that
give some advice what's wrong with this
uh to be fast I'd say like after
hardship comes ease and sometimes the
hardships of this life should be what
drives us to want to work harder for the
next life because we know what Allah has
prepared to read about Jannah and
paradise on what's prepared for you and
when you suffer in this life and you're
going through that hardship that should
make you want to work harder to get to
Jannah so the first thing is to start
with the pray if the prayer is good and
everything else will be good in shar
life the prayer is bad then everything
else will go bad never give up never
give up never give up do that action
turn to Allah know so many people have
come to me and said they sinned and it
feels so bad that they feel they're too
bad to even pray that this deed is for
the sake of a lioness in accordance with
the Sun our goal mate with you and pray
Allah well it can accept it from you in
sha Allah yeah backing up go ahead pray
pray pray and and you know what brother
cuz he got to Omar Regan shirt on mhm
um when you find that you're upsetting
them the people that you're talking to
stop tell them oh I don't mean to offend
you I don't mean to upset you
that's not I'm sorry
the judge when they see that you're so
passionate about something that you want
to control yourself from getting into
continue arguing that's Dawa in itself
and in people don't stop keep on praying
because there's hope for all of us I
feel like I'd have done so much dirt if
a lost 100 dollar saved me he can save
everybody I promise you just pray any
God look hold on you is a hope it is
everything under the Sun and now they're
feeling like their father is sir is
their hope is that so hope I'm going to
quote one of my dearest friends who will
be with us here in sha Allah - Ana one
of my dear beloved friends Imam Suraj
there's always hope because if Allah
Azza WA JAL wished to create a creation
they did not sin he had already done
that he had already done that with his
angels and when Allah said I will create
and make a caliph on earth the Angels
didn't understand they said why will you
come create one they will commit
mischief a lot of simple response was I
know what you do not know because Allah
Azza WA JAL can be known through his
greatness with his creation of the
heavens and the earth and the angels he
can be known through many of his
beautiful attributes but one of his
greatest attributes only becomes
perfected through this creation of the
insane engine and that is his attribute
of mercy the ability to forgive the
ability to turn to those who turn to Him
repent if Allah did not create people
who would sin no one would ever on
Hosmer see no one would ever understand
Allah is forgiveness so if you commit
sin no you are doing that which is part
of your nature but it does not become
part of your identity until you return
to Allah Azza WA JAL and seek His
forgiveness and repentance and lastly
the prophet alayhi salaatu wa salaam
said if the son of Adam did not commit
sin Allah would just just get rid of
that creation and replace them with
people who would commit sin so that they
would turn to Him and repent to him
because indeed in our repentance
we show the great need that we have for
Allah and we allow Allah Azza WA JAL to
show the greatness of his mercy okay all
right
yes thank you very much may Allah the
Peter to heaven early ward you did so
much I like to thank all of you guys for
sitting attentively and let's take the
advice let's work to please our Creator
before we meet our crater by doing all
the wonderful things the beautiful
things essence told us to do so we can
be in Jenna so we can be in general
because this life is short and it will
all end very soon
so let's not get hypnotized by the
turtle ization and the designs of this
world
let's get hypnotized by gender and
strive to the best the best in character
the best in deeds and actions before the
angel of death comes to snatch our soul
out of our body thank you very much
Allah reward you peace assalamu alaikum
ease humanity this is what we need for
you and me peace the solution for
humanity eaten
these pieces what we need a piece movie
open your eyes your heart your mind
seek the truth and you will find the day
is clear from night as darkness easy
[Music]